If you're wondering where is Dr. Anthony Foushee?
Where's he been lately?
He has not been talking to Donald Trump that
we know Dr. Foushee has been less and less
frequently seen publicly.
But we've now learned that Dr. Foushee has
not briefed Donald Trump on Corona virus in
two months, has been dissuaded from doing
too many public interviews by the Trump administration.
And if you're surprised by this, you've just
not been paying attention.
Months ago, the Trump administration stopped
the corona virus.
Press briefings, especially after the entire
look at injecting bleach, an alcohol fiasco
that Donald Trump was involved in.
And for all intents and purposes, they've
decided this is a political decision, not
a medical one.
They've decided the pandemic is over.
We're reopening now.
If there are embers, we will put them out.
We've done the best testing and the most testing
and we've got therapeutics and vaccines are
going well in all of this stuff.
Foushee signals.
You know, I don't know that things are going
that well.
He says, I'm speaking to Trump less and less
frequently.
I'm briefing Trump less and less frequency.
Frequently, Trump takes on the language of
victory.
And we just see Dr. Anthony Foushee almost
completely disappeared in the last 10 days.
Dr. Foushee starts being really clear.
We're not doing well.
We're headed towards a hundred thousand cases
per day.
We had seventy one thousand cases per day
a few days ago.
We're not handling this correctly.
If you look at other countries and you look
at us, it's clear that things aren't going
well.
So what is the outcome?
The outcome of Foushee telling the truth is
that the Trump administration and the White
House tried to stop Foud.
She's TV appearances.
This is the stop testing to stop cases mentality.
We want to have a lower case number.
Just stop testing as much and our cases will
go down.
Don't like what Anthony Foushee is saying.
Just don't let him say it.
It won't change whether we're headed to one
hundred thousand cases a day.
But at least you won't hear it from Foushee.
It's like saying, you know, if we didn't do
any pregnancy tests, we wouldn't have any
unintended pregnancies because we just wouldn't
have the tests.
And of course, the reality is Trump failed.
The administration failed.
The world has stopped laughing at us.
Now they're crying.
They are they are horrified by what they are
seeing here.
And, you know, it's like we look around the
world.
Do we understand by we I mean, does our government
understand why South Korea still doesn't have
300 total deaths and we're having 700 to a
thousand a day?
It's because they took this seriously.
It's because they developed a test and rolled
it out quickly.
They did contact tracing.
They isolated people with symptoms.
Everybody wears a masks.
Why does Japan have under a thousand deaths
total despite having a population of one hundred
and twenty five million people and being geographically
close to the virus, his origin in China?
It's because they took it seriously and everybody's
wearing masks.
And it's not just the public facing dismissals
of Foushee that are concerning.
Again, he hasn't briefed Trump in two months
and he hasn't even spoken to Trump since early
June.
The White House publicly has turned on Foushee.
They've put out statements lately saying,
you know, we're concerned because Foushee
has gotten a bunch of things wrong.
They even took the time to put together a
list of things Foushee has been wrong about
things from early in the pandemic, like when
Dr. Foushee said there probably isn't much
asymptomatic spread.
And of course, this is a fallacy.
This is a novel corona virus.
Everybody got things wrong.
The people who said no one would die got things
wrong.
Trump saying we have 15 cases which will go
to zero.
That was wrong.
The difference is Foushee corrects himself,
as science does, since it has a built in error
correcting mechanism.
Trump never apologizes.
Trump never corrects himself.
He never admits that he was wrong.
That's the danger.
And none of this is surprising.
I mean, at this point, there are almost as
many conspiracy theories floating around about
Dr. Foushee as there are about Bill Gates.
And it's not a big shocker that all of a sudden
Trump is no longer listening to Dr. Foushee.
The only shocker is Foushee hasn't been fired.
Now, we could if we wanted to criticize Dr.
Foushee, we could say he was too soft on Trump
early.
He shouldn't have sugar-coated the job.
The administration was doing early.
But I get the logic.
If Foushee just straight up calls out Trump
early and sounds the alarm says red alert.
This guy's incompetent.
He's failing.
He probably gets fired right away.
And there's a calculus to be made.
Does a sort of restricted foushee.
But in a position of power.
Give us a better outcome than Foushee being
fired and replaced with some total Trump sycophant?
I don't know the answer.
I get it.
Foushee likely made the call that he thought
was the best in the net.
It's not easy, but one argument would be Foushee
has effectively been fired anyway in the sense
that he's been sidelined.
He doesn't talk to Trump Trump and he's dissuaded
from doing interviews.
I'm not pretending to know the answer.
One last thought I tweeted recently.
We all know that eventually when it's over,
they'll try to blame Foushee and not Trump
in some of the sickest revisionist history
you can imagine.
I tweeted that early this weekend.
The reality is it's already happening.
It's already happening.
And when we you know, they say the winners
get to write history.
Who are the winners here?
If people keep dying and dying and dying,
I don't know.
And we can't allow them to revise history
in that way.
We'll continue covering this on our Instagram
page.
Follow the David Pakman show on Instagram
at David Pakman show and follow me while you're
there.
I ran into unentitled.
Guy yesterday in Boston, and I called him
out and I filmed it, and it's on my Instagram
page.
OK.
I'm half kidding, but I'm serious as well.